bonjour aujourd'hui on va sortir un peu
de ma période médiévale chéri pour par
les épidémies insurrection barricades
censure de la presse on va parler des
journées des 5 et 6 juin 1832 je n'ai
aucune idée de ce qui va se passer
pas d'inquiétude j'étais là au sommet de
la barricade
j'ai tout vu mais je suis prêt à
témoigner bon allons-y alors
[Musique]
pour vous expliquer le contexte si vous
n'êtes plus à jour dans vos frise
chronologique en 1832 nous sommes sous
la monarchie de juillet et le roy et
louis philippe en 1830 a eu lieu une
révolution appelé les trois glorieuses
qui a mis fin à la restauration et au
règne de charles 10 cette révolution
ayant amené à la mise en place d'un
nouveau roi louis-philippe si vous avez
bien suivi
il existe plusieurs courants
d'opposition en 1832 des républicains
même s'ils sont assez peu influent
beaucoup de déçus du pouvoir en place et
des légitimistes les personnes qui
voudraient ramener au pouvoir charles 10
qui est exilé en angleterre
1832 c'est aussi l'année où une violente
épidémie de choléra touche la france
c'est une pandémie qui est parti d'inde
qui a touché le monde entier c'est pour
ça que ça s'appelle une pandémie
elle arrive en france vers mars et fait
19 morts à paris en six mois ça me
rappelle une épidémie de peste qu'on a
eus vers 1400 femmes bref le climat à
paris en juin 1832 et légèrement tendus
le 16 mai le président du conseil
casimir perier l'équivalent de notre
premier ministre meurent du choléra
du fait des circonstances inhabituelles
de la mort du président du conseil
le roi ne nomme pas de remplaçant
pendant cinq mois et garde donc en place
le ministère perrier ce qui fait qu'il
reprend discrètement les rênes du
pouvoir
le 22 mai 39 députés de l'opposition se
réunissent et rédige un compte rendu qui
critiquent la politique menée par le
ministère en place ils se réunissent
chez l'ancien président du conseil
jacques laffite qui s'était fait
remplacer par casimir perier ne porte
donc pas vraiment dans son coeur dans ce
compte rendu rédigé par les députés ils
font la liste des promesses que le
ministre n'a pas tenu il accuse le
gouvernement d'avoir violé liberté est
entretenue l'agitation dans le pays mais
il ne condamne pas la monarchie
comme je disais avant la publication
assez peu nombreux et influents et il ne
voyait pas de problème d'incompatibilité
entre la monarchie et la liberté
jusqu en 1847 les républicains étaient
très peu représentées dans les
institutions politiques et dans
l'opinion publique et il ne pensait pas
que la monarchie de juillet pourrait
prendre fin le dire au xvème siècle
n'ont plus jamais on se serait imaginé
ok continue ce compte-rendu constitue
tout de même une condamnation violente
de la monarchie de juillet et fait un
appel du pied à tous les citoyens qui se
sentent en manque de révolte la
restauration et la révolution sont en
présence
la vieille lutte que nous avions cru
terminer recommence les républicains et
les légitimistes sont au taquet et
attendre la moindre petite occasion pour
passer à l'action
déjà le 2 juin lors des funérailles du
mathématicien evariste galois tué lors
d'un duel de 3000 personnes défilent
dans paris dont des membres de la
société des amis du peuple qu'on
retrouvera plus tard il ne se passe rien
mais le cortège est très encadrée par
les gardes qui craignaient une émeute et
on en arrive au 5 juin 1832 lors des
funérailles du général la marque lui
aussi emporté par le choléra
plutôt républicain et surtout très
populaire à partir de là je fais une
petite pause sur les sources dont on
dispose pour les 5 et 6 juin 1832
contrairement à la révolution de 1830 ou
à celle de 1848 on ne déborde pas
d'éléments sur la révolte de 1832
elle est rapidement considéré comme
assez négligeables comme elle n'a pas
mené à grand chose et on en conserve des
traces dans les archives la presse des
registres des hôpitaux et des morgues et
dans certains livres qu'ils ont
racontées l'événement les principales
sources dont on dispose sont des
messages transmis par les différents
garda jambes police ministre qui
participe à la répression de l'événement
on a très peu de témoignages des
personnes qui ont construit des
barricades qui ont participé à la
révolte
la parole est plutôt aux rancoeurs et à
moi et à toi si on veut au matin du 5
juin 1832 ont donc lieu les funérailles
du général la marque qui en a laissé une
dans le coeur de nombreuses
personnalités notamment des généraux
étrangers et lafayette qui intervient
pour prononcer un hommage à la marque
la foule est constitué de plusieurs
milliers de personnes dont des étudiants
des membres de la société des amis du
peuple et à partir de 11h30
il quitte le domicile de la marque pour
commencer à défiler dans paris
plusieurs incidents se produisent en
chemin place vendôme des soldats sont
insultés parce qu'ils ont refusé de
présenter les armes sur le passage du
défilé vers midi un soldat et molesté
par ce qui l'aurait insulté le général
la marque mais on n'est pas sûr de ce
qui s'est passé rue de gramont c'est au
tour du duc de fitz james d'être pris à
partie
il aurait refusé d'enlever son chapeau
sur le passage du général donc on lui
jette des cailloux
des chaises donc il commence à y avoir
plusieurs rapports de police au fil de
l'après-midi et vers 16 heures le
cortège arrive au niveau du pont
d'austerlitz
là on ne sait pas vraiment ce qui a
commencé les meutes lafayette aurait
demandé à la foule de se disperser un
étudiant aurait crié 1830 duration
juliet aussi voilà faisant référence à
la révolution de juillet à 17 heures des
carabiniers sont envoyés sur place se
prennent des jets de pierres et c'est à
partir de là que la fusillade des buts
sans qu'on sache vraiment qui a tiré le
premier
18h à présent on sait que plusieurs
personnes ont été tuées au pont
d'austerlitz et que des insurgés se
dirigent vers une caserne pour voler des
armes
21h c'est le bordel dans tout le centre
de paris place royale place de la
bastille et dans les rues du marais où
des barricades commencent à se dresser
les soldats en ont déjà détruit
certaines aussi pour cela il demande aux
riverains d'illuminer les rues et dans
les hôpitaux et les morgues les
premières victimes commençaient à
arriver comme ça commence à sentir le
roussi le roi décide de se rendre à
paris
ça peut sembler bizarre mais pendant la
révolution de 1830 charles 10 étaient
restés bien au chaud chez lui à saint
cloud et ça n'avait pas vraiment plu
louis-philippe veut éviter ça et montrer
qu'il intervient dans les évènements en
se rendant sur place durant la journée
du 6 juin les combats continuent dans le
centre et le nord de paris
mais les soldats gagne du terrain george
sand qui vivaient dans le centre de
paris à ce moment là il y avait la
malchance de vivre près d'une morgue qui
plus est témoignent de ces événements
dans une lettre qu'elle rédige quelques
jours plus tard le 6 juin à tuer indiana
son roman pour un mois emma ajouté si
brutalement dans la vie réelle qu'il me
semble impossible à présent de jamais
rêvé à des romans finalement les
derniers lots de résistance se trouve
autour du cloître saint mary et de la
pointe saint-eustache et sont repris
vers 17h30
en fin d'après-midi les combats sont
terminés et la victoire revient au sol
d'un nom n'a pas encore fini avec cette
histoire
oh non déjà je tiens à signaler que les
soldats les gardes nationaux était très
désorganisée ils ne trouvaient pas leur
point de rassemblement certains ont fui
face à nos malgré les ordres ils vous
ont quand même battu encore là toi oui
bah toute façon tout ça c'est à cause de
la propagande
je vois pas en quoi ça explique votre
défaite censure de la presse théorie du
complot ce n'était pas joli à voir
j'ai l'impression que tu cherches un
changer de sujet mais allons-y d'accord
durant les 5 et 6 juin à la presse a été
surveillé de très près
le journal officiel le moniteur
universel à publier tout ce qu'il
voulait par contre les journaux
d'opposition le national la tribune sont
saisis le numéro du 6 juin et mis sous
scellés interdiction publiés c'est
valable à paris et dans les villes de
province où la nouvelle commence à se
répandre par exemple à strasbourg les
journaux d'opposition restent interdits
les 7 et 8 juin 1832 évidemment le
moniteur universel nous a traité d'
anarchiste de bande de chouans alors que
le national nous appeler le peuple tout
simplement tout cela permet d'éviter
d'autres émeutes en métropole n'y a que
quelques troubles qui éclate mais qui ne
dure pas la forme rapidement les autres
départements et les pays étrangers que
tout est sous contrôle et on écrit un
beau récit pour montrer comment s'est
terminé l'événement dans ses récits en
héroïne le roi n'a pas fait grand chose
et on glorifie la prise du cloître de sa
mairie le dernier bastion de la
résistance
elle est même qualifiée de centre des
opérations des insurgés mais ça c'est un
petit peu exagéré
par contre françois vidocq bon je vais
pas faire la biographie ici aurait
collaboré avec les autorités en
infiltrant des barricades en envoyant
certains de ses agents aussi mais ça
n'est pas quelqu'un de très
recommandable alors on passe sous
silence
on ne parle pas non plus la prise de la
mairie du viiie arrondissement où on a
pu rentrer comme dans un moulin
manon la parole n'est pas vraiment aux
insurgés survivants mais c'était qui
s'est insurgé au final remarquable
transition qui était-il comme je voulais
dit on n'a pas vraiment de récits de
leur part dans les journées qui suivent
on accuse les légitimistes ceux qui
veulent ramener sur le trône charme
disent les républicains voire même un
coup monté de la police
j'adore les théories du complot déjà on
ne sait pas vraiment combien ils étaient
les premiers journaux parlent de 1500
demi insurgés mais sans aucune preuve
environ 1500 personnes sont arrêtées
pendant ou dans les semaines qui suivent
l'insurrection et on compte environ 300
morts dont au moins la moitié du côté
des insurgés
ces vagues d'après les registres des
morgues on a une idée approximative de
qu'ils étaient la plupart avaient moins
de 25 ans habitait dans le centre de
paris et était célibataire
les exercer des métiers dans les
domaines du commerce
l'artisanat des services ceux qui ont
été tués au nord faire la porte de saint
denis était souvent un peu plus âgés et
venaient de province et c'est tout
devait y avoir aussi beaucoup
d'étudiants par mieux mais dans les
registres des morgues la plupart des
personnes restent anonymes parmi les
personnes arrêtées à la barricade de
montmartre il y avait aussi quelques
gardes nationaux c'est cocasse et
puisqu'on en parle on avait réussi à
monter environ 200 barricades et pas
juste des bouts de bois mis les uns
au-dessus des autres
certaines formes et des réseaux
complexes sur plusieurs rues qui passait
entre les boutiques et les ateliers des
rez-de-chaussée
qu'est ce qui s'est passé après
l'insurrection dès le 6 juin la ville de
paris a mis en état de siège pour un
mois environ
en étant en place l'état de siège on
s'assure que les personnes qui seront
arrêtées seront jugés par le conseil de
guerre et non par les tribunaux
habituelle ce qui promet donc des peines
un peu plus lourde
cet état de siège est très critiquée par
les républicains qui parle de coup
d'état et par des avocats qui le déclare
illégale il est donc levée dès le 29
juin
ce qui est aussi vue comme un signe de
faiblesse du gouvernement de la part de
la population et de la part des pays
étrangers
si vous n'arrivez pas à assurer l'ordre
on critique si vous êtes trop
autoritaire on critique dans les
semaines qui suivent insurrection des
personnes sont arrêtées des associations
sont fouillés les journaux
perquisitionné et on demande aux
médecins dans les hôpitaux de dénoncer
les patients qu'ils viendraient de
l'insurrection
mais finalement la tension retombe assez
vite les deux premiers procès qui ont
lieu devant le conseil de guerre mène à
des acquittements et ensuite comme
l'état de siège est levé on revient à
une justice normale
les personnes jugées sont souvent
condamnés à des peines de travaux forcés
ou de détention au total deux cent
soixante et une personnes sont jugées
sur les quelques 1500 arrestations et
des groupes entiers sont parfois blanchi
comme 216 étudiants de polytechnique qui
avaient été arrêtés on relâche aussi la
surveillance sur les blessés qui sont
encore à l'hôpital
en quelques semaines événements
commencent déjà à passer dans l'oubli et
on en parle de moins en moins dans les
journaux du côté des vainqueurs les
policiers et gardes blessés pendant
l'insurrection
environ 240 personnes reçoivent chacun
50 mille francs de la part de l'état
l'insurrection des 5 et 6 juin 1832
semble donc tomber rapidement dans
l'oubli
et n'être qu'une répétition raté des
événements de 1848
pourtant elle est restée dans l'histoire
en partie grâce à un auteur victor hugo
avant lui il ya eu deux tentatives de
romans en reprenant l'insurrection
le cloître de saint mary de marius rails
du cei et l'horreur d'un beau jour de
noël parfait
les deux livres sortent dans la foulée
des événements fin 1832 et en 1833 et
sont tous les deux brunes est interdit
et noël parfait et condamné à deux ans
de prison et 500 francs d'amendé
les misérables paraissent en 1862 trente
ans après et pourtant victor hugo a
hésité à sortir cette histoire parce
qu'ils avaient peur de la censure
il avait déjà raconté des événements au
moment où il s'était produit comme
george sand puisqu'il en avait été
témoin aussi en 1832 et landi ceci
émeutes du convoi de la marque folie
noyer dans le sang
nous aurons un jour une république et
quand elle viendra d'elle-même elle sera
bonne
mais ne crions pas en mai le fruit qu'il
ne sera mûr qu'en juillet sachons
attendre la république proclamée par la
france en europe ce sera la couronne de
nos cheveux blancs mais il ne faut pas
souffrir que des goujats barbouillées de
rouge notre drapeau et ce qu'il vient de
me traiter de goujat j'aime cet homme en
1832 il qualifie les insurgés de bouge à
30 ans après il en fait des héros entre
temps il est devenu républicain il a
compris que les classes les plus
populaires de la france n'était pas à
prendre à la légère dans les misérables
il ne fait pas un récit des événements
en tout cas par un récit fidèle
pourtant il était là et c'est ce qui
s'est passé et où ça s'est passé
mais ce n'est pas le but de son histoire
il prend certains éléments avérés des
noms de personnes ou de re retrouvé dans
les archives mais il y ajoute ses
propres personnages inventés gavroche
il ajoute aussi des événements d
révolution de 1830 et de 1848 et même
certains éléments de la bataille des
thermopyles dans les misérables et
glorifient l'insurrection de 1832 et
surtout l'insurrection en elle même et
on peut lui reconnaître d'avoir su
glisser une insurrection oublié trente
ans après dans un roman qui a largement
traversé les siècles depuis
ils ont à traverser il s'en fiche c'est
super bien écrit ainsi donc ce dernier
l'histoire de l'insurrection des 5 et 6
juin 1832
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu je profite
de la fin de cette vidéo vous annoncer
que je lance une page tipi si vous ne
connaissez pas c'est un site de
financement participatif où vous pouvez
donner de l'argent si vous voulez
financer ce que je fais sur youtube je
vais pas m'attarder plus là-dessus tout
sera expliqué sur la page en elle même
dont vous retrouverez le lien dans la
description si vous voulez allez voir je
vous souhaite aussi une bonne nouvelle
année et on se retrouve très bientôt
pour une nouvelle vidéo
au revoir et non conformes aux standards
and blood et the music hall les échos
[Musique]